a visit to the dentist's office is rife
with sensations sounds and sights
some may be terrifying
while others are meant to relax you
sounds like these might also reduce pain
studies from as early as the 1960s have
shown that sounds including music can
alleviate pain in people
we know that when certain types of
sounds are around activity changes in
pain related parts of the brain
but exactly how sound turns into pain
relief is still uncertain
a new study took to the simpler smaller
brain of mice to understand how music
can make the pain go away
first the researchers inflamed the
mice's paws
they then played different sounds
classical music
a dissonant version of the same song
and white noise
from behavioral tests they found that
all three of these kinds of sounds
provided pain relief
but only at a certain volume five
decibels above the ambient noise of the
room
or about the sound of a conversation
with someone
any louder and the effect was gone
after exposing the mice to this subtle
white noise for multiple days
the pain relief continued
even a day or two after the exposure to
the white noise was stopped
if the sounds were merely distractions
from the pain then lasting pain relief
would not be expected
after recording the mice's brain
activity while listening to this ideal
level of noise the team found that fewer
neurons fired in the mice's auditory
cortex the hub of sound processing
the signal from the auditory cortex
connected to the thalamus
which processes every sense except smell
hearing the sounds reduce the auditory
inputs to this key pain processing
region
seemingly relieving pain in mice
in humans more areas are involved in
pain processing so the pathway is likely
more complex
and we might be more sensitive to noise
type
classical music or jazz might be the
best pain relievers for us
but this study provides clues as to what
might be happening in mouse brains and
beyond
and for now could be used to make lab
mice a little more comfortable during
experiments
until we uncover the mechanism in people
it won't hurt us to keep listening to
music in the dentist's chair
[Music]
you